The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILL MA: I guess
I'll get started.
So all right, cool.
OK, so before I
get into any hands,
I wanted to-- this
is really loud.
Before I get to
any hands, I want
to talk about tournaments
versus cash games
since I haven't really
made the distinction yet.
So essentially-- so
this is a big chart
with all the differences.
So when you guys play
in the things online,
those are called tournaments.
So in the tournament, you
sort of buy-in for a fixed
amount of play chips.
case, it's not that relevant.
It's like one play dollar.
And then you get, for coming
in the top 20% a round,
you're going to get some amount
of play chips paid out to you.
And like, if you win,
you get the most.
And if you just
barely make it, you'll
probably make back
like two play chips.
So you'll profit one
play chip or something.
So that's how tournaments work.
And that's sort of what,
throughout this class so far,
I sort of assumed all the hands
are taken from tournaments.
So there is a different
way to play poker.
And a lot of you
might have actually
been introduced to
poker like this--
so, you have like
sort of a home game,
where there's just
a bunch of friends,
you're playing at
someone's house.
And you all buy in for
some amount of play chips.
And basically, you
can play, and people
can join the stock any time.
If you lose all your play chips,
you can just buy in for more.
It's not like tournaments
where once you're out,
you're eliminated.
And you can never go
back into that tournament
and cash in to go
buy in whenever.
You can hit and run people.
You can come try to
make a bit of money
and then just leave as
soon as you make a bit.
So what are the
main differences?
So I wanted to highlight the
differences between the two
types of games and talk about
why we mostly choose students
tournaments in this class.
So everyone knows the definition
of what a tournament is,
what a cash game is.
So let me talk a bit more about,
what are some differences?
In cash games, usually,
the stakes are fixed.
So usually, it will say we're
playing for like one play
dollar, two play
dollars, or something
like that, whereas
in tournaments, I'm
sure as you've noticed,
the blinds keep going up.
The blinds start 10/20
in your tournaments.
And then they become 20/40,
and then like 40/80, or 30/60.
Actually, there's a
15/30 level, I think.
So it's 15/30 and
20/40, and then 25/50.
And it keeps going up.
and the reason this is the
case is so that eventually
the tournament ends, because
if the blinds don't go up,
the tournament will
take forever to end.
So what's a big factor about
tournaments versus cash games?
In tournaments, you have
no control over your table.
You just join in the tournament,
and you're put at some table,
and you've got to do your best
at the table you're placed at.
And the fact that there's
not this much metagame,
I think is one of the reasons
it's much easier to analyze
poker hands in terms
of tournaments,
because in cash games, if
you're at the cash game,
and everyone's really, really
good, you could just choose,
I don't want to play in
this cash game anymore.
I'm just losing my money.
And you could choose
to stand up and leave.
And there's a lot of
decisions of this form.
So there is more
metagame required.
And in tournaments, the
general goal is to survive.
You're just trying to get
eliminated as late as possible
to maximize your payout, whereas
in cash games, a lot of it
comes down to, if there's
one bad player at the table,
you're trying to target
that specific player.
You're trying to
do everything you
can to get in hands
against that player,
and exploit them, and win a
lot of money against them,
and risk a lot and
stuff like that.
There's less focus on the
math of poker and more focus
on specifically targeting
certain players.
Tournaments-- there's
frequent but fixed losses.
So if you were
playing tournaments
for real money, how it
works is most of the time,
like 80% of players don't
get paid anything back
from the tournament.
So when you play tournaments
most of the time,
you're going to lose, even
if you're really good.
You're not going to win
more than 50% of the time.
So you're going to lose,
lose, lose, lose lose.
And then you're going to get
a big win and then win a lot.
And then it's going to be
lose, lose, lose, lose,
and you're going to win a lot.
Sort of like playing the
lottery, whereas cash games,
anything can happen.
You can lose a lot.
If you are having a bad day
and you decide not to quit,
you could lose all your
money, buy back in,
lose all your money,
by back in, eventually,
lose all the money
in your bank account.
That could happen.
You could also win a lot.
So anything can happen.
But in some sense,
tournaments is more variance.
So like when I was talking in
the first class about the law
of large numbers and reaching
the long run, it does, overall,
in some sense, take longer if
you're playing tournaments,
because in tournaments, you
do need to occasionally get
the big score in
the tournament--
it's sort of like
winning the lottery--
to make back all your money.
And if you don't, then you
won't make back all your money.
I argue that tournaments,
I think, are more fun.
They're more exciting.
If you make it far
in a tournament,
eventually, it comes
down to just two of you.
It's pretty exciting.
Also, tournaments have a
wider range of situations.
So in cash games, usually,
it'll be a fixed number
of players at the table.
And players will have a
similar number of big blinds,
because whenever you lose
a bunch of big blinds,
you can always buy back in
and get those big blinds back
by putting more
money on the table,
whereas in tournaments, we
have to learn how to handle I,
think interesting,
mathematical situations where
you have one big blind.
How do I play it optimally?
And stuff like that.
The last thing is if
you play at a casino,
another good thing about
tournaments is relatively,
the casino makes a lot less
from tournaments and cash games.
Cash games, just as a fraction
of how much money you wager,
the casino takes way more
compared to tournaments.
Tournaments-- what the with
the house takes is very small.
OK so those are the
main differences.
But I did want to
comprehensively
go through the
differences, because if you
do decide to play poker,
these are essentially
the two ways to play it.
So I wanted to make
sure everyone is
well aware of the differences.
So yeah, so why I chose
tournaments for the class--
I think there's less metagame.
I think it's more exciting.
I'm mostly a tournament
player, myself,
although I have played cash
games for extended periods
during my career.
Yeah, there's a wider
range of scenarios.
And I think it's
more applicable.
I think the MIT Poker Club--
the event they're
running in January
is a tournament, because
tournaments are exciting.
OK, so are there any
questions about this chart?
OK, cool.
Yeah, our club
actually has both--
I mean the points-only
tournaments count.
But if you look at this
thing above, then actually,
the pen works now.
I don't have to draw in here.
OK.
If you look there, then
these are the cash tables.
And you could, in
theory, sit down there
and play for play money.
And if you do lose all your
play money in those cash tables
to a shark in the class, and
you have no more play money,
and you can't join
tournaments, you
can always refill your play
money and join the tournaments.
So that's why it's
called "play money".
Only tournaments
count for standings.
And if you want to see the
standings, you have to--
oh, I see.
They annotate.
So you see that you've got
to click the blue arrow,
and then you can
see the standings.
Some people ask me about this.
So if you want to see your
standings, how many points
everyone has, how many points
you have, you can click that.
You can click there.
OK, let's get into
some poker hands now.
That being said, I highlighted
all these differences
about cash games
and tournaments.
But good poker is
essentially good poker.
If you're good at one, you're
probably good at the other.
The difference is
still rather small.
It's more based on, how
much risk do I want to take?
What kind of schedule
do I want to play?
And that determines which one
you choose to play rather than,
am I better at
tournaments or cash games?
At least once yours--
except at the very top
levels, there there really
is no difference between--
there's no such thing as
a cash game specialist,
except at the very, very
top where it's possible
the best cash game players are
good at cash games compared
to the best tournament players.
But when you're just starting
out, if you're good at one,
you're good at the
other, essentially.
All right, cool.
So today, I'm going to talk
about some preflop play.
Last class, I focused
on post-flop flight.
The first class, I talked
a bit about what hands
you should open with
preflop But I didn't really
say that much about
playing preflop.
But it's of the most
important parts of the hand,
because it determines
what cards are playing
for the rest of the hands.
So first of all, I wanted
to run through some numbers.
It's good to have
a sense of these.
You don't have to
memorize all of these.
But it's good to have a
reasonable idea of equities,
of specific hands versus
specific hands, when you get it
all in preflop.
And I've classified
this to make this
roughly easier to memorize.
So the first example, which is
sort of the dream situation,
is you have a bigger pair
against a smaller pair.
What's the best
situation that you
can be given preflop in poker?
So, what's the best
hand you can have?
It's aces, right?
But you don't want aces
and for everyone else
to have 3/2 offsuit, because
they're just going to fold.
So you want aces, and you want
someone else to have kings.
One of my screen names
is actually, please
give me ace ace against
king king or something,
on a site, because it really is
the best situation you can hope
for, because
they're going to put
all their money in with kings.
And so roughly, when you have
a bigger pair against a smaller
pair, your an 80/20 favorite.
So you win 4/5 of the time.
And the edge dwindles a bit as
you get to like, 33 versus 22,
because there's a higher
chance both pairs will
be counterfeited.
Like the board can come
66 77 8 or something.
And then pocket threes
ties pocket deuces.
And an equally good
situation is one pair
against zero overcards.
So ace ace against
ace king off it's
also a very good situation.
You're actually 93% there,
because you dominate their ace.
So there's very few
ways for them to win.
Pocket aces against 6-5 suited--
this is actually
the hand that's best
against aces, other than
aces itself, is 6-5 suited.
And aces is only 77.5%.
But it's still ludicrous.
So pocket jacks against
10-9 suited, 81.7%--
so, some rough numbers.
10-9 suited is pretty good.
But pocket jacks crushes it
because having two jacks blocks
a lot of their straight-outs.
Pocket queens against
7-4 is very good,
because 7-4 off is not
suited, not connected.
And the best you can
do preflop is actually
king king versus king two off.
If you have pocket kings
against king deuce off,
I think that's the highest
equity you can possibly
get in preflop is 94.6%.
And pocket kings against
king two suited is 89 points.
So look how much
better king two suited
does than king two
off against king king.
The fact it's easier to
make a flush is so relevant.
We'll talk more
about this later.
OK, the next few categories--
so a pair against one overcard.
So you're still a favorite,
but less big of a favorite.
Instead of an 80/20,
you're a 70/30.
So queen queen against
ace jack off is 71.7%.
Queen queen against ace
jack suited is a bit worse.
Queen queen against
ace queen suited
is actually much worse than
queen queen against ace jack
suited.
I think this is a bit
counterintuitive, because with,
against ace jack
suited, I always
thought they have more outs.
They can hit three jacks.
But it actually
turns out, the fact
that they have a
queen to prevent you
from hitting three of
a kind in the situation
they've already had an ace, is
actually a lot more relevant.
So queens is much worse
against ace queen than is jack.
And pocket eights
against ace two off--
70.2%.
Pocket threes
against ace two off
is a bit worse,
because once again,
small pairs can
get counterfeited
when you all-in preflop.
OK, a similarly good
situation, which is the 70/30,
is when you are, quote,
"dominating" the other person.
So "dominating" means one
of your cards is the same.
But the other card is different.
And yours is higher.
OK, so ace king off
against ace queen suited--
pretty good situation
to get it in poker.
You're at 70%.
If you are suited, and they
are not, then you're 75%.
If neither of you
are suited, it's 74%.
Yeah, ace king off
versus king queen off.
You're actually a bit better.
So, ace king off against ace
queen off, you're at 74.4%.
Ace king off is king
queen off, you're 74.8%.
And you're a bit better,
because it's harder
to tie with the ace.
So when you both
have an ace, it's
possible the board will come
with two pairs, so like 6,
6, 7, 7, 8.
And then both of you will have
two pairs of sixes and sevens
with the ace kicker.
But that's less likely to
happen if they don't have--
like if your bottom card
is their top card instead
of your top card
being their top card--
One thing to keep in mind is
ace five off against ace two off
is barely a favorite at all.
So it's nowhere near as good as
ace queen off against jack off.
Anyone have any
idea why that is?
Is it draw?
Right.
Exactly, yes.
So the five and two are
going to get counterfeited.
The five kicker is going to
get counterfeited a lot more
often, because if four
cards on the board come,
that's higher than five.
The five is going
to be irrelevant.
So that's a good
thing to remember.
Let's look at some more numbers.
This is one thing that I've
always thought is really cool.
Two overcards versus
a pair is actually
very close to a 50/50
for the most part.
Ace king suited against
pocket twos it's 49.9%.
I actually showed you
in the first class,
if they don't have
a two of your suit,
then it's actually like 50.1%.
So ace king off versus
pocket twos is 47.4%.
Note that 10/9 suited
against pocket twos
is actually a 54% favorite.
It's much better than ace
king against pocket twos,
because 10/9 can make a lot
more straights and flushes.
And the fact that you're
making a pair of tens instead
of a pair of aces,
is irrelevant when
the thing you're trying to
beat is a pair of deuces.
Ace king off versus
pocket queen is only 43%.
Even though people
call it a coin flip,
it's actually much
worse than a coin flip.
So yeah, this is actually one
of the first things that drew me
to Hold'em.
When I found this
out, I was curious.
I was wondering, the person
who invented the rules
of Hold'em, did they invent
it so that this is a 50/50?
Or was it just by coincidence
that is [INAUDIBLE] 50/50?
But I think it's very cool that
it turns out to be a 50/50.
OK, so the last cases--
there's some weird cases where
all four cards are different.
Roughly speaking, when all
four cards are different,
the guy with the highest
card is going to be a 60/40.
I mean, this is very
rough, because it's
hard to encompass all the
different types of scenarios
under the same umbrella.
But the thing that matters
is having the highest card.
So let's see.
So AB versus CD, which
means you have two cards
above their two cards.
You can be as good
as 67.7% if it's
like ace king off
versus queen seven off,
because queen seven off
has no straight-outs
and no flush-outs.
AC versus BD, it's
about 60 versus 40.
AD versus BC, it can
be as low as 50/50.
So ace two off against
10-9 suited is only 51.6%.
So that's sort of the worse
case for AD versus BC.
You can look through those
numbers more on the slides.
And you can also get it
yourself on PokerStove.
Or a lot of websites, you
can compute the equities
of a hand versus another.
But it's good to have some
rough ideas of these categories.
When is it an 80/20?
When am I a
[? four to one ?] favorite?
When am I a 70/30 favorite?
When am I a 50/50?
When am I a 60/40?
OK, so one thing that I hope you
sort of got from these numbers
is that suitness matters
a lot when you're behind,
and matters not that
much when you're ahead.
So if you look at these
numbers, the gain in equity
of ace king suited when--
sorry.
The gain of equity of ace
king when ace king is suited,
is only 1%.
You only increase your
equity from 74.4 to 75.4.
But if ace queen is suited,
then the equity of ace king
drops by 4% instead of 1%.
And the reason, essentially,
is if your hand is bad,
you need as many ways as
possible to try to get lucky.
And being suited is one of them.
But if your hand is
already very good,
you just really need your
opponent to not get lucky.
And you being
suited is only going
to be relevant if they first
hit a pair to beat you.
And then you need to hit
a flush to beat them.
So that's one thing
to keep in mind.
So like with ace
king, the difference
of being suited and unsuited
doesn't matter that much.
But with a hand like
9-8, being suited
is way better than
being not suited.
And shrewdness is also
important for implied odds,
as I talked about last
class, because you
can make much better decisions
post-flop if your hand is
suited.
So that's roughly some hand
[? equities ?] to remember.
Now, we're going to talk
about some preflop all-ins,
so going all-in preflop.
OK so this class--
most of this class, this is
going to be a bit boring maybe.
These are not really
highlight reel plays.
And this is about routine,
making good decisions
that increase your preflop
equity by a couple percent that
will--
but it's really these
boring decisions, I think,
that make you win right, not
the occasional brilliant thing
that you see on TV.
So if your goal is to get
on TV, then studying this
is maybe pointless.
But if your goal is to
make expectancy, win money,
essentially, then it's really
the simple, boring decisions
that affect whether you win,
not the one-time crazy bluff
you pulled off against Phil
Ivey that makes you a winner.
Let's talk about this a bit.
So the main thing is, don't be
afraid to go all in preflop.
I didn't really stress this yet.
But one thing I tend
to see people do
is, you are too afraid to
put all your money in preflop
because you would think
it's gambling or something.
It is a lot of luck.
You essentially put
your tournament life--
you let it ride on a coin flip.
So it does seem scary.
But the thing to
remember essentially,
is late in the tournament, the
antes and blinds are so big.
And if you ever can win
the blinds by going on,
that's such a large gain
relative to what you risk,
and also, any two
cards of a chance
against any other preflop.
So what was the rule I said?
So the rule I said
in the first class
is, when the
effective stack size
is less than 12 big blinds,
when there is antes,
then just go all in if you're
going to play the hand at all.
And if there's no
antes, then you
need to be a bit
shorter, because you
don't want to risk 12 big
blinds when there's no antes.
So you only want to risk like
10 big blinds without antes.
But this is the rule that I
outlined in the first class,
roughly, and when you can go on.
And one thing I wanted
to talk about, too,
before we get to
the first example,
is from the small blind--
in the first class, I said,
your button-opening range
is similar to your small
blind opening range.
And why was this, even
though from the small blind--
so when it's folded to
you in the small blind,
you may have to get through one
more player, whereas when it's
folded to you on the button,
you need to get through two more
players.
So it seems like you could
play a lot more hands
from the small blind.
And another advantage of
playing from the small blind,
is you've already
put in half a blind.
So the amount more
you're going to put in
to play the pot is less,
is half [? blindless. ?]
But we said that
being in position--
especially [? when we
sell this last class--
?] being in position
is so important,
that the fact that you're in
position on the button and not
in position was the small
blind, meant about balanced-out
the advantages of playing
hands from the small blind.
So we said, roughly
speaking, you
should be similarly willing
to raise hands from the button
and raise hands from
the small blind.
But for all-ins,
position doesn't matter.
If all the money goes
in the pot preflop, then
who gets the [? act ?]
last postflop?
Doesn't matter,
because there's no more
actions to make postflop.
So for all-ins, your
small blind all-in range
can be a lot wider than
your button-on range.
And furthermore, I think the
threshold of how many bets
you can have to go all in is
a lot higher, because even
with like 15, even
with 20 big blinds,
I often go all in
from the small blind
if I know the big blind
is a competent player.
From the button, I
would pretty much very
rarely go on for 20 big
blinds, because I'm not
that sad if I just
raise it to 2.25
and then call, because
I play the rest
of the hand in position.
But from the small blind,
when I know that if they call,
I'm playing the hand
out of position,
I really want to
avoid this situation.
So going on for a huge
amount from the small blind
is usually OK since there's
only one player behind anyway.
Let's look at a
sample situation.
And I'm going to first
analyze it theoretically.
And then I'll try to go
through a bunch of examples.
So do we go all in or fold here?
And let's suppose we're
reasoning exploitatively.
So this was level 2 thinking,
not level 3 thinking.
So if we're reasoning
exploitatively, what
we're asking ourselves
is essentially,
what's exploitative thinking?
We model our opponent, give
them a probability distribution,
and then playing in a way
that maximizes our expectation
relative to the Bayesian
probability distribution we
put on our opponent.
You can ask yourself,
is a blind a gambling
Player?
Is it likely he or she will
call with a wide range of hands?
How crazy have I been playing?
Will he give me any
credit if I go all in?
Suppose the pay
bubble doesn't matter.
Suppose it's far
from having to try
to survive to make the next
pay increase or whatever.
So let's do this.
What do we think he's calling?
OK so I want to see
what you guys think.
Does someone want
to give me a hand
that that you think he's
calling, or definitely calling,
or definitely not calling?
You give me a no-brainer.
I just want people to--
so what's the hand he's
obviously not calling?
AUDIENCE: 2-7 offsuit.
OK, good.
WILL MA: 2-7 offsuit.
What's the hand he's
obviously calling?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
WILL MA: OK, so let's try
to zero in a bit more, OK,
don't worry.
It's OK.
So tell me what
hands you think he
might be calling that are a
bit worse than pocket aces?
What do you think is
the smallest pocket
pair he's calling?
If you're not sure,
let me ask you.
What's the smallest
pocket pair you
would call if you don't know
anything about the small blind?
So it's 15 big blinds.
It's a 15 big blinds all-in-one.
OK, who would call pocket fives?
Who would call,
call pocket twos.
Who would call ace seven suited?
Who would call a
queen jack offsuit?
OK, so I guess we
have a rough idea of--
so assuming you're playing
against someone in this class,
let's just say when you look at
that sample, just sort of guess
what they're calling.
So I had this range.
Maybe it's a bit more
ambitious than what
people put up their hands for.
I said they would call with any
pocket pair, any ace, king ten
offsuit, king eight suited.
So this is what I said they
would call with just 25%
of hands.
Maybe in reality, they
call with even less.
Maybe in reality, they only
call 20%, 15% of hands.
But this just further
emphasizes my point.
So we assume, they
call it 25%, let's say.
OK, let's do the math.
Let's now assume
we have 10 offsuit.
OK, so let's do the
math against this.
Oh, sorry.
So what is the equity of ten
eight offsuit against their 25%
Range?
So when we get called, we're not
going so well, because they're
only calling 25% of hands.
So their hand is going to
be good when they call.
We're only 36%.
So let's do the math.
So 75% of the time,
they're going to fold.
And we're going to
win 2.5 big blinds.
Why is it 2.5 big blinds?
There's a big blind
that we're winning,
there's a small blind
and then there's one
big blind from the antes
that we're winning.
And it's 3.5.
We count the small blind,
because even though we
put in the small blind, the fact
that you put it in the pot--
it doesn't matter who
put it in the pot.
The fact that it's
already in the pot
means we're winning the money.
That make sense?
So 25% of the time,
he's going to call.
And then when this
happens, 36% of the time,
we're going to win the all-in.
And we're going to win
16.5 big big blinds.
Because we're going
to win the 1.5--
we're going to win
the small blind,
the antes plus his entire
15 Big Blind stack.
64% of the time
we're going to lose,
and we're going to lose 14
and 1/2 Big Blinds, which
is how much we wagered
to do this all-in.
So you can do the calculation.
And it's actually very positive.
We're making an expectation,
an entire Big Blind
by going all in.
So now let's suppose
we had a worse hand.
So let's suppose
we had 3-2 offsuit.
We can do the same
calculation again.
The only thing that
changed is, now
we only have 28% equity
instead of 36% equity.
So 3-2 offsuit is
actually a worse hand
than 7-2 offsuit for a
lot of all-in purposes.
Because 7-2 offsuit is,
like, the worst poker hand
against a range of strong hands.
But against a range
of any two cards,
3-2 off is actually
worse than 7-2 off
because seven high is
relevant if they had six high.
Anyways, so you do
the calculation,
and you find that this is
still an excellent play.
So going on with
3-2 offsuit, it's
actually not a crazy bad play.
It looks like a crazy
bad play on paper.
And I'll tell you, in reality,
it is a crazy bad play.
But according to
this calculation,
it's actually not
a crazy bad play.
You're actually
earning 0.42 Big Blind.
OK, so what's wrong?
What's wrong?
Why does our calculation
say 3-2 off is a good play?
And there's no mistake
in the calculation.
It's not because of a
mistake in the calculation.
AUDIENCE: Because of
the high probability
that he's not going to call you.
WILL MA: Right, exactly.
OK, good.
Yeah, so basically remember,
we did this calculation
using Level 2 reasoning,
exploitative thinking, right?
We built a model for him.
And if our model is correct,
then actually 3-2 offsuit
is a good all-in.
So what this is showing
us is actually--
the point is, if our
model is correct,
then they're making a mistake.
Then he's making a mistake
by only calling 25% of hands.
It's just too small a fraction.
It's too small a fraction
of hands to call with.
So I guess the
lesson sort of is--
so when I took the
poll around the class,
you guys wanted to call
even less than 25%, right?
25% still includes
Ace-2 offsuit,
and still includes hands like--
let's see again.
It still includes
hands like Queen,
King-10 offsuit, Queen-10
suited, King-8 suited.
So even 25% is sort of
too low in the sense
that it allows a Small Blind
to shove any two cards--
shove means all-in, shove
any two cards profitably.
And in reality, it
might be the lower
if people were
being truthful when
they put up their hand for what
they're calling with, right?
So basically my
point is, I think
people are too afraid
to go all-in preflop.
Going all in preflop
is fine, basically.
So let's suppose we're
the Big Blind now,
and we're considering
adding Queen-Jack off
to our calling range.
So I'm saying, OK,
you're making the mistake
as a Big Blind of
only calling 25%.
But what's wrong with
my reasoning, right?
The thing that's wrong
with my reasoning
is, that's only mistake
from a Level 3 reasoning
point of view, right?
That's only a mistake in that
it's not theoretically optimal
because in theory, the Small
Blind could shove any two
cards profitably.
But if the Small Blind isn't
actually shoving any two cards,
then maybe this is actually
the optimal range to call.
If the Small Blind is shoving
too small, then maybe 25%
is the optimal
strategy for the Big
Blind from that point of view.
So we can do a calculation
with Queen-Jack.
So let's assume the Small
Blind only shoves top 25%
of hands instead of 100%.
Then your equity is only 42%.
And what equity do we
need to call all-in?
We need to call 14
Big Blinds, right?
We need to call 14 Big Blinds.
And if we call,
the pot will be 31.
So we need 14 over 31,
which is about 45% equity.
We only have 42, so we actually
shouldn't call anymore.
So it's possible the Big
Blinds play is correct.
But the point is, someone's
play isn't correct.
So I also wanted this
example to give you
another idea of what sort of
optimal Nash equilibrium play
is.
So I'm going to--
so let's draw a chart of
what is in game theory called
an iterative best response.
So how this works is, I fix
a strategy for one player.
I take the best strategy
for the other player
at exploiting this strategy.
And then I fix that
strategy, and I come back.
So I fix the strategy
for the Big Blind, which
is only call 25% of hands.
And then I ask myself, what's
the best way for the Small
Blind to exploit this?
Well, it's to shove
100% of hands,
right, by the calculation.
So now, if the Small Blind
is fixed on this strategy,
what's the best way for the
Big Blind to exploit this?
Well, it's to call with
anything basically,
because you know they're
shoving anything.
So it's a call with a very
wide range, say, 67% of hands.
So once the Big Blind
is calling too much,
how does the Small
Blind exploit this?
Well, now they
tighten up, right?
They only shove
their good hands.
And that's fine, because
they're getting paid off
very often when they
shove their good hands.
But once the Small
Blind realizes
they shove only
their good hands,
then the Big Blind's
like, oh crap,
I shouldn't be
calling 67% anymore.
I'm going to call less, 30%.
So overall, let me
draw sort of a diagram
of how it's going to work.
So you can see, right?
0, 100 Small Blind.
So essentially how it works is--
let me just put some markers.
So how it's going
to start out is,
the Big Blind calls 25%,
right, which is here, 25%.
And then the Small Blind, to
exploit this, shoves 100%.
Then the Big Blind
goes to call 67%,
and then the Small Blind
will respond by shoving 40%.
These numbers are
approximate, right?
Then the Small Blind
will shove too little,
and then the Big Blind will
sort of call too little.
And then it'll essentially
go here, and then go here,
and then go here,
and then go here.
So essentially, the point
is it's going to converge.
It's going to zero in on this
blue line, on these blue lines.
And the thing that
it zeroes in on
is basically what's called
the Nash equilibrium.
So you can actually compute
the Nash equilibrium
with a computer in this
case, which is what I did.
And this is what the
Nash equilibrium is.
So the optimal thing to
do is for the Small Blind
to shove about 66.8% of
hands, and the Big Bind
to call about 38.5% of hands.
And I think if you
play reasonably,
reasonable stakes online
poker tournaments nowadays,
this is what most
people know how
to do because most people will
have a computer program that
can do this
calculation for them.
But it's quite
loose, essentially.
So remember, the situation was
15 Big Blinds, there are antes,
and you're in the Small Blind.
You should be shoving
2/3 of hands, roughly.
And the Big Blind should be
calling almost 40% of hands.
And this is the ranges.
And as you can see, the Small
Blind can shove 4-3 suited.
So suitedness is very important.
But if your hand is unsuited,
then 7-6 offsuit is a shove.
Oh, 6-5 offsuit it
as a shove, too.
But 9-5 offsuit is not a
shove because it says 9-6
off plus, which means
9-5 off is not a shove.
So it's always a good idea
to know the Nash thing just
for preflop.
Because even if you're trying
to exploit your opponent,
you want to make sure you're
never going too far off
from the optimal play.
Because whenever
you get too far off,
you could potentially
be getting exploited.
Yeah, but I mean, you don't
have to do exactly this.
I'm not saying everyone
should do exactly this, right?
If you think you're
smarter than your opponent,
and you have a good
model than your opponent,
if you think the Big Blind is
calling way fewer than 38.5%
of hands, then you can go in
with a lot more than 66.8%
of hands.
Just make sure if
you do decide to try
to exploit your opponent,
you do the exploitation
in the right direction.
If they're calling too little,
then you need to shove a lot.
If they're calling
too much, then you
need to shove very little.
That makes sense
to everyone, right?
That's the right direction
to exploit your opponent.
And similarly, if the
opponent is shoving too much,
then you're going to call a lot.
And if they're
shoving too little,
then you call very
little as well.
But Yeah, but what's good about
the Nash equilibrium strategy
is you can't be exploited.
You know no matter what they
do-- the optimal, basically
the reason why this is
called the convergence point
is because if the Small
Blind is shoving 66.8%,
the best for the Big Blind
to do against that is 38.5%.
And the best you shove against
38.5% calling range is 66.8%.
So it essentially
converges, that's why
it's called an equilibrium.
So hopefully this gives you a
better, a more concrete example
for those of you who haven't
seen what a Nash equilibrium is
exactly, of what I mean by
optimal Level 3 reasoning play.
OK, so that's enough of that.
So now let's go do
some concrete ranges.
So now you can ask me, how do
we learn these ranges, right?
I showed you the Nash range
for one specific situation.
But the situations
you can enumerate.
There's going to
be a lot, right?
So I showed you the range for
Small Blind versus Big Blind,
and there's 15 Big Blinds.
But what if it's 14 Big Blinds?
What if it's 13
Big Blinds, right?
What if it's 10 Big
Blinds with no ante?
So essentially
it's a combination
of memorization, understanding
theory, and then extrapolation
slash interpolation.
So let me just show
you a few more.
So just to give
you a rough idea,
this is where the memorization
slash interpretation comes in,
because if you have a few
baselines to go off of,
you can sort of use rules
that theoretically make sense
to extrapolate, right?
So here's button, 10 Big Blinds.
43.9%, and this is
roughly the hands.
Oh sorry, is it clear what
this range of hands means?
I guess I never
really explained.
Basically s mean suited, o means
offsuit, and plus just means
any hand where the denominations
are strictly higher.
If you don't know exactly what
it means, it's not a huge deal.
But roughly, you want
to sort of know what
this is, what this is saying.
So there's a few weird cases,
but roughly, if it says Ax+,
that means any Ace,
any hand with an Ace,
suited or unsuited
you can go all-in.
So 43.9%-- So in
terms of extrapolation
and interpolation--
I just want to
make sure everyone
gets the directions right.
So if I move from
button to the cutoff,
does the fraction of
hands go up or down?
AUDIENCE: Down.
WILL MA: Down, right?
So the fraction of hands goes
down because from the cutoff
there's more players
to get through, right?
So you need a better hand.
You can't-- so the fraction of
hands you can shove goes down,
right?
That make sense to everyone?
So make sure you get
the direction right.
And then what if the number
of Big Blinds goes up or down?
So let's say it's 15 Big Blinds.
I guess 15 is sort of too
much to go all-in with,
but let's say it's
12 Big Blinds.
Does someone have a guess
what the percentage might be?
You just have to get
the direction right.
Someone?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: 40%.
WILL MA: Yeah, 40%.
That's about right.
That's about right, basically.
So the percentage
will go down a bit.
And what if you only
have 5 Big Blinds?
Does someone want to
guess the percentage?
AUDIENCE: 60%.
WILL MA: 60%, yeah.
That's about right.
So try to get the
directions right.
If you have a few
baseline points,
and if you can get
the directions right,
that's a very
important first step.
So here's another data point.
Cutoff, 7 Big Blinds.
It's 38.8%.
So notice that the cutoff,
this situation compared
to the first one, you're one
position worse because you're
cutoff instead of button.
But you're risking a lot less,
so you only have 7 Big Blinds.
But the percentage
is still going down.
So I think I said
this first class
as well, the position matters a
lot more than the number of Big
Blinds because for the
number of Big Binds,
even though you
are, in some sense,
risking a lot more as
you have more Big Blinds,
it's also harder to get called.
If I go all in
for 10 Big Blinds,
they're going to fold
a lot more than if I
go all-in for 7 Big Blinds.
So that's why the
position actually matters
a lot more than how many bets.
OK, so lojack--
So that's hijack minus one.
So that's two over
from the cutoff.
It's only 28--
10 Big Blinds is only 23.4%,
but it's still nothing.
Not nothing.
So under the gun nine
handed with 3 Big Blinds,
it's actually pretty high.
It's 24.1%.
So you can go look
at those on your own.
You can also calculate on
your own in certain websites.
Yeah, so this will
roughly give you an idea
of the shape of the graph.
So this is under
the gun all-ins.
It's a bit approximated,
but with 15 Big Blinds--
I know I recommended with 15
Big Blinds not to go all-in.
And I think that's a
good recommendation,
but let's say you told the
computer they were forced
to go all-in with 15
Big Blinds, and they
had to calculate the
Nash equilibrium,
this is what it would spit out.
It would say, you go
all-in with this 6.2%.
And with 10 Big
Blinds, it's 13.4%.
With 5 Big Blinds, it's 33.3%.
So it actually increases
quite a lot for under the gun.
For under the gun, the amount
of the fraction of hands
you can wager as a function of
how many Big Blinds actually
goes up quite a lot.
AUDIENCE: Question.
WILL MA: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: For example,
you have 15 Big Blinds,
and you get an Ace-Jack
offsuited, what would be--
how much would you raise?
WILL MA: Oh, I would raise to 2
Big Blinds, or 2.25 Big Blinds.
AUDIENCE: That's it?
Very little?
WILL MA: Yeah.
For all hands, I essentially
raise to 2.25 Big Blinds.
AUDIENCE: But it goes from
2.25 Big Blinds to all-in?
There's no middle range?
WILL MA: Right, right.
There's no in between, yeah.
So the reason
essentially is, there's--
so let's say you raise
to 5 Big Blinds, right?
This is essentially equivalent
to an all-in, except worse.
So why is it equivalent
to an all-in?
Because if your opponent has
pocket Aces, or a good hand,
not necessarily pocket Aces,
they're going to go all-in.
And pretty much,
you have to call.
I mean, if you knew they
had exactly pocket Aces,
you could fold.
But it's possible for them
to play a balanced strategy
where they could have
pocket Aces, or Ace-King,
or pocket 10s, or whatever, and
you're forced to call anyway.
So essentially if you make it
any more than 2.25 Big Blinds,
you put in enough chips
that your opponent can just
play a strategy that forces you
to go all-in when they want to.
And so it's basically
strictly worse than just
going all-in yourself.
Yeah, good question.
But yeah, with 15 Big Blinds,
I would recommend just
raising small, although
I don't think going
all-in is the end of the world.
OK, so this is roughly what the
shape of the curve looks like.
So here's another example.
So for hijack, from 15 Big
Blinds to 10 Big Blinds,
it actually changes very little.
I guess it changes somewhat--
23.4% to 28%.
And then with 5 Big Blinds,
it goes up very fast.
So as the number of Big Blinds
goes down, it increases a lot.
But the difference-- but
the change from 15 to 10
isn't that much.
I guess under the
gun it's a lot,
but for hijack,
it's not that much.
So just give you some ideas.
I don't expect anyone
to do this perfectly.
I'm trying-- I gave you
a bit of data points.
Just try your best
to extrapolate a lot,
try your best to extrapolate
slash interpolate.
If you're off by a
lot, that's fine.
The biggest thing is, just try
not to get the direction wrong.
Don't think, if I'm
one position worse,
I can shove more
hands, or something.
So a few more pointers
about going all-in preflop.
So here, this is definitely
a good play, I think.
So you have pocket
fours from hijack.
You have 15 Big Blinds,
which is more than what I
said you should go all-in with.
But I think-- but going
all-in is a good play,
instead of just raising to
two times the Big Blind.
Because small pairs,
while having good
implied odds when very deep--
so in the last class, I talked
to you about set mining.
I said small pairs are great
when you have 100 Big Blinds
because you can try to
hit three of a kind,
and just win a massive
amount of money when you do.
But they actually have
terrible implied odds
when it's 20 Big Blinds
deep because you only
hit three of a kind
one eighth of the time.
When you do, the total
effective stack size
is not enough for you
to recoup your losses.
And when you don't,
you're just always going
to be sitting there
with a pair of fours,
and there's always going to
be higher cards on the board.
It's going to be Ace,
Jack, 10, and you're always
playing a guessing game.
Does my opponent
have a better pair?
And you just can't
make good decisions.
So that's why with small
pairs, just going all-in, even
for a lot of Big
Blinds, is reasonable.
So here's another example.
Queen-8's good.
Normally you wouldn't
go all-in with that.
You normally would
just fold under the gun
if you had a lot of chips.
But with only 5 Big Blinds,
going all-in is fine.
Another factor that's actually
sort of relevant here is--
this is sort of a
higher level thing,
but it's good to keep in mind
is, when you're under the gun,
in some sense you
have the least to lose
by busting the tournament.
So by going all-in, you're
risking busting the tournament.
So this is not true in a cash
game, but in a tournament
it's true.
You want to go all-in
from under the gun when
you're really, really short.
You have very little to lose
by busting the tournament
because if you don't bust the
tournament, the next hand,
you're the Big Blind,
which really, really sucks.
So even though you
busted the tournament,
you busted the tournament in a
situation where the next hand
you would have had to
pay the blind, which
is one fifth that your
stack, in this case.
So going all-in is OK.
Ace-2 suited is another
example of a hand that's
pretty good to go all-in with.
Because if they have a better
Ace, you're still suited,
so you have chances
of catching up.
And the fact that
you remove an Ace,
there's less Aces out
there for them to have,
is quite relevant, actually.
The fact that there's
three Aces out there
for them to make a good hand to
call you with, than being four.
Everyone know what
I mean by that?
So if you have an Ace,
there's one less out there
to go around.
Yeah, so we go all-in here.
And yeah, here we have 17 and
1/2 Big Blinds from the button.
But I think going all-in with
Ace-4 off is fine, basically.
So it's a lot.
It's 17 and 1/2 Big Blinds,
but once again, Ace-x offsuit
has terrible implied odds.
It also protects your
small pair shoves a bit.
So when I said this
pocket twos hand--
sorry, this pocket
fours hand, I said
you can go all in
for 15 Big Blinds.
But what's one problem if you
follow this strategy exactly?
It's whenever you do
this, your opponent
knows you have pocket twos
or pocket threes, right?
Then what can they do?
They can call with 10-9 suited,
which is not a good hand.
Like 10 high against
a 15 Big Blind shove
shouldn't be possible,
but they can.
So if you also do this with
Ace-x, it protects you a bit.
Yeah, with 7-6 suited,
I think it's also OK.
This is a similar
story, pocket Deuces.
7-6 suited has great implied
odds when you're 100 bets deep,
and making straights and
flushes is very relevant.
But when you're
only 20 bets deep,
and you're just trying
to make a big pair,
essentially, small
cards just aren't good
at making big pairs,
can't make big pairs.
So once again, going
on is acceptable.
So one thing to
watch out for is--
I actually swept
this under the rug
in the last couple of slides.
But in all these
cases I showed you,
there's actually a pretty big
disincentive to go all-in.
Does anyone see what it is by
looking at the stack sizes?
So they've always been
the same actually,
but does someone see a
pretty big disincentive?
Yeah, Vincent?
AUDIENCE: Other people have
much larger stacks than you.
WILL MA: Right,
although actually I
should say this, other people
having much larger stacks
than me is actually an
incentive to go all-in.
The reason being,
it's possible--
let's say you go all-in and
then someone calls, and then
another guy re-raises all-in
and the first guy who called
folded.
Then what would happen
is, you're still all-in.
And if you win the pot, you now
triple up instead of double up,
and you still only
have to beat one hand.
Did that make sense?
I can draw it if it
didn't make sense.
So you go all-in for $5,400.
So let's say this
guy calls for $5,400.
Let me use a different color.
This guy calls for $5,400.
And then let's say this guy
goes all-in for $12,000.
And then this guy folds--
which he shouldn't be doing
because he definitely has
odds to call, but
let's say he does fold.
Then the situation is great
because how the rules work
is, now the pot--
so now this guy is going
to get back $6,600.
And the pot-- But $5,400 of
his is still in the middle.
And essentially, there's
this $5,400, this $5,400,
and your $5,400.
And you're only
against his hand.
And if you win, you
get all the money.
So you actually triple
up instead of double up.
So that's actually
a good incentive.
But yeah, that's a
good observation.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Because your
going all-in is profitable
because there's a high
probability of other people
folding.
But if two people call
or three people call,
you get a lot of
people can call it,
and then your odds are not
very good when they call.
WILL MA: Right, right.
Yeah, that is relevant, yeah.
So multiple people
can call, but the Nash
ranges that I presented
do take that into account.
So the Nash ranges,
the Nash calculations
do take into account that
multiple people can call.
You have to look carefully
at the stack sizes.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [? They now only ?]
have $2,100?
WILL MA: Right, good.
Good.
Damn, I wish I'd brought one
of those gift certificates.
I still have some, but OK.
So this is actually
very relevant.
And I swept this
under the rug, but let
me clear the annotation.
The Big Blind only
has four bets,
only has 4 Big Blinds
in this situation.
And they're basically
guaranteed to call.
That's not a terrible
result for you
because there's a good chance
that just have absolute trash,
and Queen-7 suited
is better than them.
But it's still worse than
being able to steal the Big
Blind for free.
So the fact that the Big
Blind is so short here
that they're basically
almost guaranteed to call,
maybe they'll fold 3-2 offsuit
is really, really bad for you.
Because your chances
of just winning down--
taking out the blinds without
having to win an all-in
is a lot lower.
That make sense to everyone?
So it's hard to do when
you're just starting out,
but it's good to
pay attention to all
the different stack sizes.
And if there's someone
behind, someone in the blinds
who is very short and who's
almost guaranteed to go all-in,
then you should be a lot
less incentivized to try
to steal the blinds.
Yeah?
All right guys, I'm going
to get started again.
So I'm going to give you a few
more examples of extrapolation.
I know this is a bit boring,
but to be honest, I think--
this is less exciting than
playing postflop, and reading
your opponent, and trying to
read what cards they have,
and trying to make
tricky bluffs.
But really, in
tournaments, the best skill
you can have when just
learning, just starting out
is knowing when to go all-in.
Because even if you're pretty
good at it versus very good
at it, the fact that,
because most hands just
come down to going
all-in preflop,
if you can increase
your equity every time
you do this by even 1%, that's
a huge game in terms of how
profitable a player you'll be.
So yeah, it's a bit boring.
But just try to bear with me.
This is, like, the
most important skill
in tournaments, essentially.
So I wrote down on this
graph the most number
of Big Blinds I'm
willing to risk all-in
for from each position.
So I want to sort of
illustrate a concept.
These numbers are actually
quite ambitious, by the way.
I think I made this
maybe four years ago
when I was trying to play
exploitatively against the fact
that the average
player was too tight,
the average player was not
willing to call often enough.
So you would be shove
more hands than Nash
because most players
don't call enough.
Nowadays, I think people
are getting closer to Nash,
so you can't really be
this ambitious anymore.
All these numbers
should go down a bit.
You shouldn't be going
all-in for that many bets.
But nonetheless, the graphs
illustrate the same point.
So I roughly-- I
wrote down in black
how many bets I'm
willing to risk
from each position
with Ace-4 offsuit.
So notice that from the
button it's huge, it's 22.
But under the gun, it's a lot
smaller-- it's only seven.
And roughly, it
decreases as a 1 over x,
curve as a inverse curve.
And that's sort of
intuitive because if you
shove from the button, you need
to be the best out of three
hands, so it's like 1 over 3.
And then you got to be the best
out of four, so it's 1 over 4,
and then 1 over 5,
1 over 6, et cetera.
So the graph is roughly--
I mean, I don't
know, let's say 88
over number of hands remaining.
Or I don't know,
something like that.
But I want to show a similar
curve with 7-6 suited.
So what do you notice
about these two curves?
AUDIENCE: Looks more
linear than the other one.
WILL MA: Right.
So this one is very curved.
This one is like 1 of x.
This one is maybe there's like--
this one it's a
lot flatter, right?
It's 9.5 under the gun, which
is more than 7.7 for Ace-4.
But Ace-4, it's 22
from the button,
whereas for 7-6, it's only 19.
So the thing is, these two
hands are a bit different.
So essentially with
Ace-4 off, it's
a hand that does poorly
against good hands,
but well against bad hands
because against a bad hand,
your Ace high is
going to be good.
And against a good hand, you're
always going to be dominated.
Like, if they call with an
Ace-Jack, or a pair of 7s,
you're going to
be at 30/70, right
Whereas with 7-6, even if they
have Aces, I mean, it's bad,
but it's the best
hand against Aces.
But basically 7-6, you're
going to be better on average.
If they call with Ace-King,
it's not a good situation,
but it's much better
than if you had Ace-4,
whereas if they
have 8-2 offsuit,
which is a terrible hand,
that actually, theoretically
is ahead of yours.
So what's the most
important thing about 7-6
suited and going on with it?
Essentially it's
having a lot of chips,
it's having a large stack.
Because you want them to fold
all of their trash hands.
And it's good when they're not
going to call you very often.
So you want to
have a lot of bets.
Whereas for Ace-4, the
most important thing is--
you don't mind if they call,
as they call with a bad hand.
So the most important
thing you want with Ace-4
is, you want to be later
in position so that you're
against your hands so that
there's less of a chance
that someone behind is going to
pick up Ace-Jack or pocket 10s.
So when you're extrapolating
slash interpolating,
try to remember this principle.
So with a suited
connector hand, it
matters a lot more how
many bets you have.
Whereas with a hand with two
unsuited but sort of big cards,
like Ace-4 offsuit,
King-8 offsuit,
I guess Queen-7
offsuit or whatever,
the thing that matters
most is having few players
left to act behind.
So I talked to you a lot about
how do you initiate all-ins
from preflop.
So what about calling
other people's all-ins?
So another thing that I
sometimes see people do
is fold with ridiculously
good odds preflop.
And similarly how you can
shove any two cards preflop,
you can also call a lot
preflop because you'll always
have some equity.
So yeah, it's difficult
to get less than 30%
equity preflop no matter
what your cards are,
unless your opponent has
a really strong range.
Like they're really tight, and
you know Jacks plus an Ace-King
or something.
It's difficult. to
have less than 30%
equity if you have an
Ace in your hand, right?
Because if you have
an Ace, then you're
either going to have an over
card, at least, to their pair,
or be dominated.
But both of those
are still 30/70s.
Only if they have
Aces are you actually
in a really bad situation.
So I wanted to show
you a hand here
that looks maybe a bit like
bad play to some of you,
but I think it's
very reasonable play.
So we have 9-8 suited,
we have 15 Big Blinds
so we don't go all-in, right?
Which is fine.
We may get $1.600.
And then it's folded
to the Big Blind,
but the Big Blind goes
all-in for 10 Big Blinds.
So normally, if the Big
Blind had covered us,
if they had 15 Big
Blinds, you would probably
fold because you have 9 high.
You probably-- you don't
have enough odds to call.
But in this specific case,
the effective stack size
is not 15 Big Blinds, right?
They only have 10 Big Blinds,
so the effective stack size
is 10 Big Blinds.
So if you do the math,
when the effective stack
size is only 10 Big
Blinds, basically you
have enough equity to call.
Even if they had 12 Big Blinds,
maybe it's very borderline.
But even if they have 12 Big
Blinds, roughly speaking,
you have enough
equity to call, right?
This is sort of the
same calculation as me
saying, if you had
12 or less Big Blinds
and you raise, and
someone goes all-in,
you basically have to call.
This is sort of a
similar calculation.
It's the same thing.
You raised, someone went all-in,
it's effectively 12 Big Blinds,
and you can call.
So this is a totally
reasonable play.
And then you just call.
If you do the math, you
need 37% equity to call.
It's possible in some corner
cases you can convince yourself
that you don't have 37%
equity, but for the most part,
I see a lot more bigger mistakes
by people folding this spot.
If you call, you're never
really making a huge mistake.
OK, fine, if they're
sort of tight,
maybe you only had 35%
equity, and you needed 37.
You made a small mistake.
But there are situations
similar to this
where you might have 45%
equity and you only 37% equity.
So it's a huge mistake.
Folding can be a big mistake,
but calling is rarely
a huge mistake when it's
12 Big Blinds or less.
So any hand that we would
raise here in the first place,
we probably would have
enough equity to call.
If I had 7-2 offsuit here,
I probably would not call.
But I would not raise
here with 7-2 offsuit.
So any that you
would've chosen to open
here, which is about 30% of
hands, or 25% percent of hands
I think you can call.
Here's another situation that
we sort of talked about already.
You have 4 Big Blinds, and
you had to pay a Big Blind.
Basically you pretty much have
to play close to any two cards
in this spot.
If you do the calculation,
right, you only need to call--
I mean, calling is equivalent
to going all-in, sort of.
If you go all-in,
you know you're
getting called
because they're going
to have almost four to one
odds, so they're going to call.
So essentially the
calculation is,
do I want to wager my
entire stack on this hand?
And you're risking 3 Big
Blinds for a total pot
of 9 and 1/2 Big Blinds.
So essentially, you only
need 30% equity to call.
And 30% equity is very easy
to have preflop, essentially.
So basically you have
to play any two cards.
Queen-8 off is way
more than good enough.
Yeah, so this is
basically the calculation
I just went through.
And yeah, like here I
think I would probably
play 95% of hands.
I think I'll fold 3-2
offsuit, 4-2 offsuit,
but I'll probably play any
hand with a card that's
10 or higher, and I'll probably
play every suited hand.
So let's talk a bit of
re-raising all-in preflop now.
And all the situations I showed
you were just going all-in,
and someone calling preflop.
So I wanted to show you.
So don't do this,
don't call preflop.
I already talked
to you about this,
but especially when
you have 10 Big Blinds.
So once again here, don't just
raise when you only have 10
Big Blinds.
That's less than 12,
so you can go all-in.
Yeah, so you basically either
want to go all-in or fold.
But I want to talk
about raising now.
So why is this so
bad, but this is OK
when we have more Big Blinds?
So now everyone has
19 and 1/2 Big Blinds.
So why is this OK?
The main reason is because--
so in the first case, right--
so I talked about this.
If you get caught, if
someone goes all-in,
basically you have
to call anyway.
So you might as well
go all-in yourself
because you're not getting away
if they pick up a good hand.
So that's the same calculation.
I'm just going to
skip that part.
It's the same calculation.
Essentially it's just
saying there's no point
to not go all-in because if
someone else goes all-in,
we're essentially roped
into calling anyway.
So the second case,
we can get out.
We can fold.
So let's keep this
in mind, right?
So in this case, we
can definitely fold.
So we can do the calculation.
In this case, we need
to call 17 Big Blinds
to win a total pot of 40.5.
We need 42% equity.
And we almost certainly
don't have this
because we raised
from early position,
they went all-in against
an early position raise,
so they probably
have a good hand.
We're almost certainly
going to be a 30/70.
So let's look at whether
we call or re-raise.
So for re-raise
sizing, so now let's
put ourselves in his shoes.
If he's re-raising-- sort
of the same principles
apply when you're re-raising.
So the advantage of
re-raising to a small size
is that, what if it's deep
enough where he could re-raise,
and we could four bet,
re-raise again, and go all-in.
Then they could fold, if they
were intending to do that.
The advantage of
re-raising to a large size
is you deny your opponent
the odds to call profitably.
And once again, if
your re-raise size
would cause you to
commit a critical portion
of your stack such
that you can't escape,
you're going to
go all-in anyway,
then you might as well
just re-raise all-in.
So it's essentially
the same principle,
but let's see this in action.
So this is what you
don't want to do.
And I see some
players doing this,
which is fine because I've
is never really explained
this in class.
But if someone raises,
let's say to $2,000,
you don't really want to
just click the raise button.
This is what would happen if
you click the raise button.
Because he raised $1,200--
from $800 to $2,000.
So if you click
the raise button,
this is the minimum
amount you could lose.
You can raise it to
$2,000 plus $1,200.
But if you look at the
odds you're giving him,
it's actually ludicrous.
They have to call $1,200.
So they would have
to call $1,200,
and the pot will be
$5,000, $5,200 $6,400--
essentially $7,200.
So it's $6,100, right?
They got to call $1,200
into a pot of $7,200.
So this size is
basically way too small.
So how big do you
want to make it?
So roughly speaking, you want
to make it 2.5 times their open.
I think that's a
reasonable rule.
There's a lot of factors
that can affect this,
but if you're not
sure what to do,
a reasonable rule for
re-raising preflop
is 2.5 times what the
original guy raised.
If you're out of
position, you might
want to raise a bit
more because there's
more incentive for
them to call if they
can play in position postflop.
But I think in this
specific spot, this $5,000
is a good size.
I'm going to skip to this slide.
But in this case actually--
can we see our stack size?
So our stack size
is only $20,000.
So in this case, I think
going on, it's a bit big.
So the thing is, if
you're going to re-raise,
it's the same
principle again where
if the amount you re-raise
to is more than a quarter
of your stack, which sort
of means you're committed
and you can't escape, then
you might as well just
go all-in yourself.
So I'd say in this hand, if
you had less than $18,000,
I would just go all-in.
Because you can't really escape.
Even in this specific case
where you have $20,000,
I don't think it's terrible
to just go all-in instead
of making it only $5,000
because it's pretty hard to fold
a hand is good as Ace-King,
even if you make it $5,000,
and then he goes
all-in for $20,000.
But I think $20,000 is enough
that you can make it $5,000.
And you can do this
with your good hands.
You can also do this
with your bad hands,
sometimes as a bluff
to balance it out.
And you can fold when you do
have a bluff and he goes on.
So that's roughly the sizing
you want to make at preflop.
And another thing I
want to say is, why
is calling a preflop raise OK?
So I said in the first class,
if no one has entered the pot,
and you're just
attacking the Blinds,
you always want to raise.
You always want to raise
to give yourself a chance
to win the Blinds for free.
You don't want the Blinds to be
able to see the flop for free.
But if someone has
already raised,
I think it's OK to call.
I mean, a hand like Ace-King
is sort of too good,
but if you have an Ace-Jack
suited or Ace-Queen suited,
I think just calling is fine.
So why is this?
So it's because-- the reason
why, in the first case,
there's no real advantage
to not raising, just calling
is because if a Big
Blind has a good hand,
they can still raise anyway.
So it doesn't matter.
But in this case, there
isn't a huge incentive
to not re-raise, right?
What is the huge incentive here?
So let me go back here.
What's the huge incentive
to just call for $2,000
instead of make it $5,000
is, if you make it $5,000,
then you give him the
option to go all-in, right?
This is a huge difference.
In the case where you're
just raising the Big Blind,
they can't go all-in.
But here you're
giving him an option.
So that's why you just
want to call sometimes
so that they can't have
the option of going all-in.
So this is a good example.
So this is now a different
scenario, but it's very--
the Blinds are only
25/50, and players
have $8,000, which is,
I guess, 160 Big Blinds.
And here, calling is definitely
a positive expectancy play
because you're in position,
it's very, very deep,
there's a lot of money
still to play for,
and you're in position for all
the rest of the hand, which
is great.
This is a good play.
So if you raise in this spot, it
could lead to disaster, right?
So what happens
here is you raise,
and then now hijack minus one,
the guy who originally raised,
they now have an option
to re-raise again,
which is what they do.
And now it's just terrible.
We basically have to fold.
We could call if
we're feeling lucky,
but we basically have to fold.
And I think calling is actually,
in reality, a reasonable play.
But basically, it's a
much worse situation
than this one where
we just called.
So yeah, that's a demonstration.
So if someone's already
raised, you can just call.
I'm going to talk more
about this next class
as well, a preflop
strategy against someone
who's already raised.
But that's one thing
to keep in mind.
Another thing I want
to go through quickly
is how do you deal with callers.
So I've said that
you should never
be just calling a pot when
the pot hasn't been raised.
But people will inevitably
make this mistake.
And usually if it's folded to
someone, no intention to pot
yet, and someone
just calls, we call--
the term in poker
is a limper, which
is a bit of a derogatory term.
Poker actually has a
lot of derogatory terms,
which is a bit unfortunate.
But I sort of have the tough
decision of either making up
my own terminology, but then
if you go into the poker world,
no one understands
what you're saying.
Or I use the same terminology,
which is derogatory.
But OK.
So we're just going
to call them limpers.
Either way, you need to be
prepared and raise their limps.
But you do need to change your
raise size if there's limpers.
So let's say normally
when it's deep,
you decide to raise to 3
Big Blinds, which is fine.
I mean, I said raise
to 2.25, but I think
it's fine if you raise to 3.
It doesn't matter that
much when it's deep.
You can raise to 3
to play bigger pots.
But if there's a lot
of limpers ahead,
then you want to
make it more than 3
because there's already
money in the pot.
So if you only raise
it to 3, you're
actually giving them to
good of odds to call.
So let's say in this
case, I only make it 3.
If I only make it
$150, then by the time
it's folded to the last
guy, their odds of calling
are going to be-- they put in
$100 into a pot of #375, right?
So that's like 3.75 to 1
odds, so that's too good.
So roughly, the
odds-- the rule is,
take whatever size you
were going to raise to,
and then add a Big
Blind for each limper.
This essentially makes
it so that the odds
are the same as before.
So in this case, if you
were going to make it 3,
I would make it 3
plus 1 plus 1 plus 1
because there's three limpers.
And of course, if you
only have 15 Big Blinds,
then in this case, instead of
raising it to 6 Big Blinds,
you might as well
just go all-in, right?
The fact that you only raise
to 6 Big Blinds instead
of going all-in is
predicated on you
having at least 25
[AUDIO OUT] to start the hand.
Or something where it's
enough to escape if something
weird happens after.
I'm going to finish off showing
you some more simple preflop
situations.
I think-- so the theme
this is being boring.
Oh, I'm sorry about this slide.
So being boring, being
simple, just playing
on simple probabilities
and using calculators
can get you very far in poker.
And I will go
through crazy bluffs
and exciting hand reads and
stuff like that as well.
But this class, I wanted
to stress the simple things
that I think are good.
So here, this is a situation.
So here you have 4-3 suited.
You're too scared to go all-in.
Can I raise to 2 Big
Blinds as an alternative?
Oh, so you're the button.
So the button only
has 8 Big Blinds.
They started the
hand with $1,600,
and they make it $400
with only $1,200 behind.
So I want to show you
why this can go wrong.
Why is it bad if you don't
follow the all-in rule?
Because now let's say the
Big Blind has 4-3 suited.
Well, if he went all
in for 8 Big Blinds,
they would have to
fold their 4 high.
I'm not going to run through
the calculation again.
But the problem is now, if
you make it 2 Big Blinds,
they could actually call your
small raise with 4-3 suited.
And they have 4.5 to 1
odds, and that's definitely
good enough odds for them.
So if our hand has 40%
equity against his range,
then it's going to be +EV.
So essentially
they're going to call,
and they're not going
to raise the 4-3 suited.
So basically they could-- so the
fact that we didn't go all-in
gives them an option, here.
With their good hands,
they can go all-in,
and rope us into getting all-in
anyway when we're the button.
And with their bad
hands, like 4-3
suited that they don't
want to go all-in with,
they can still call
and see a flop.
But the point is, we're
essentially-- this
is essentially their strategy.
You can read it.
I'm not going to read
through this slide now.
But the point is, we're giving
them an opportunity to make
a better play than they
otherwise could've.
If we just went all-in,
the choice is theirs.
They either call or they fold.
But here, essentially they
can take their best hands,
and they want to get all-in
with and go all-in, and we call.
Or with their worst
hands, like 4-3 suited
that can still
call to see a flop,
they can call and see a flop.
And we're just letting
them realize a lot
more equity than we need to.
So let's say, OK, fine.
If you want to get around
that, you can make it $800.
And if we make it $800, it's
more or less equivalent.
So if they were going
to fold, then they
were still going to fold.
If they were going
to re-raise all-in,
then we're still going to call.
And then-- it's
mostly equivalent.
I'd say in this exact
situation, making it--
if you raise to $800,
it's pretty much the same
as making it $1,600.
But on some off
chance, it's still
possible you're giving
them a free option.
Like maybe their better
play with 4-3 suited
is still to just call.
And then if the flop comes
really, really bad for them,
like Ace-Ace-King.
Maybe that's not even that bad.
But 9-8-7 or something, I don't
know, they could maybe fold.
So basically I think just
keeping it simple is good.
So one concept I'll finish
on is, there's this idea of--
so I have talked about-- all
this stuff I'm saying about
letting them go all--
giving them the option is bad.
But what if you think they're
so stupid that if you give them
the extra option,
they're actually
going to make a mistake,
and giving them strictly
fewer options is actually bad?
You actually just want
to give them more options
even though it's free
options because they
might make a mistake.
So this is slicing
in from a while ago,
but Bill Chen sort of gave a
very good theoretical example
of this.
So Bill Chen, he actually
might give a guest lecture.
The last lecture, we
haven't decided yet,
but he might come and speak for
the last lecture of the class
this year.
He wrote the book called
The Mathematics of Poker.
He's one of the world experts
on the math behind poker.
He's a math PhD.
He's currently a trader at
Susquehanna International
Group.
Anyways, this is what Bill
Chen calls a sucker bet.
And when you see your
opponent do this,
you should almost
be a bit offended.
Like I sometimes-- this
occasionally, very rarely
happens.
But when it does happen,
I'm sometimes very confused
because my opponents
shouldn't be doing this.
So maybe they're stupid,
and they don't go all-in
because they're stupid,
and they're actually
giving me a free option.
But maybe I'm actually
the stupid one.
Maybe they think I'm so
stupid that if they gave me
the free option, I'm
going to make a mistake.
So if you do get in a
situation like this,
it's actually sort of an
interesting theoretical
question, I think.
If you're sitting in exactly
Big Blind's shoes, you saw.
Let's say you know the button
is a competent player, too.
This makes it worse, right?
If you know the button
is a competent player,
then you're saying, I
guess this sort of reveals
what they think of me, if
they're giving me a free option
to see the flop here
here 4-3 suited.
They must I think I'm
going to mess it up
so bad that they'd rather give
me this free option than not.
But it's an interesting
concept to think about.
And sometimes it does happen.
Another sort of
example of a sucker bet
is, I guess I was talking
about last class on the flop,
or even on the turn
or whatever, you never
really want to bet a very
small fraction of the pot.
Like, if the pot is $100, and
then your opponent checks you,
and you bet $1 into $100, it
doesn't-- it's not a real bet.
It's $1 into 100.
It's essentially an epsilon bet.
It's essentially a zero bet.
But what does it do?
It gives your opponent
a free option, right?
Now they can check-raise you.
If they-- now it's
saying, OK, I bet $1.
Now you have a second chance
to bet on the flop, right?
You check the flop, but I'm
going to bet $1 into $100.
And now if you want
to make it $50,
you can re-raise
my $1 bet to $50.
And now if you want, you can.
And if you think your opponents
going to make a mistake,
you can try to do this.
It is a very specific
exploitative strategy,
but it's interesting
in that it's
so obvious as an
exploitative strategy.
Anyway, I think it's an
interesting theoretical thing.
So I think one-- a
few more examples.
So once again, these
are all simple hands,
but I just wanted to
show you there's--
the only way you can
mess up this hand
is by not going all-in.
You only have 15 Big Blinds,
someone's already raised a lot.
You don't really want
to try to do something
cute like slow playing,
especially-- if you had Aces,
maybe slow playing is OK.
But with just Ace-King, any hand
is so much equity against you.
And you just want to go all-in.
Here's an example where someone
in lead position raises,
and you have a pocket pair.
You can go all-in.
And this is pretty
good because you
do pretty well against
their range that calls you.
So this is a pretty
good play often.
I'll talk more about
this in future classes.
But if you're defending your
Blinds often with small pairs,
re-raising all-in, even
if it's for a lot of bets,
is a reasonable play because
the hand-- they might even
fold pocket 3s, pocket 4s.
I think it's quite likely.
Yeah, I think the
Nash equilibrium
is to fold pocket 3s, pocket
4s if you have enough chips.
But when they do call
you, even if they
have a hand like Ace-King, you
still have 50% equity, right?
So small pairs are pretty
good at just re-raising all-in
against late position steals.
So all-in here is good.
So the last example
is also easy.
It's essentially saying,
so under the gun raises,
hijack minus one calls.
You have a great hand on the
button, and only 20 Big Blinds.
You just go all-in.
There's no reason to be
cute and make it $8,000,
I guess unless you were trying
to sucker your opponent.
I'm going to stop
here, and then--
so the next class,
I'll maybe run
through a tournament
history next class.
I'll show you guys a history
of me playing a tournament,
and try to discuss
some of those decision.
That will be one of
the next three classes.
All right, cool.
Thank you.